thank you very much good morning ladies
and gentlemen I'm also very proud and
honored to be here and to see so many
unique specialists unique group of ICT
professionals so I am very happy to open
this fiber to the home conference the
12th conference here in Warsaw maybe I'm
not so energetic as this young
colleagues before but I would like to
say several sentences to you because the
priority of the ministry I'm responsible
is exactly fiber-to-the-home we have
ambitious plan which started and I hope
will finish in this 5 years time to
achieve this ad india agenda Digital
Agenda goal as you know 25 years ago
Poland was reborn to a new life to be
free democratic a modern market-oriented
country state but also maybe you don't
know 25 years ago Poland was connected
to internet the first email was sent
from friends to Krakow exactly 25 years
ago at the very beginning of 1990 a
group of engineers received this email
in Krakow at one of our universities how
the country have the life changed you
can see now but the real cyber
revolution started I suppose and maybe
it's not the best idea to check our
ambitions plan in the next coming five
years and to see the real result in a
future in the end of the program we
establish in Poland under the title
digital Poland operational programme you
would like to invest in this area over
to
billions of euro and much more also
using private funds the first phase
infrastructure infrastructure of course
the Poland today is a huge
constructional field I can share with
you with the report I've got plus two
days ago you would like cover the
problem by backbone Network for
high-speed internet and this first phase
will give us 45 thousand of kilometres
of the of the network we are in the
middle of the road but my satisfaction
is that during last two months we've
built more than 10,000 of the network
ten thousand kilometers of this network
so i hope that in next coming six months
we will achieve this first goal the next
phase is of course dedicated network
today to the house to the each citizen
of poland the infrastructure is the one
pillar the second pillar is e
administration the e service and the
third one competition so we are working
on this tree earlier areas in parallel
way being here the first time but I hope
the not last time might be is not the
best idea to meet after this 55 years
here in also again I would like to wish
you all the best to wish you fruitful
discussions important important contacts
I hope does this 12 conference will be a
source of very important knowledge for
you and I think I hope that you will
have a nice stain also a nice days also
because of
seeing their the city maybe after the
discussion after the panel's after the
important conference maybe you can also
enjoy was so like this young generation
show us at the very beginning so have a
nice day in Warsaw thank you for being
here together and hoping we'll meet each
other soon thank